[Music]
welcome to the show i'm zerena maxwell
and we begin tonight
with fear and loathing on the campaign
trail closing messages in presidential
campaigns are usually focused on the
issues
but on this election eve the trump
campaign seems to be putting the
emphasis on
intimidation and litigation the
president is promising to send lawyers
into states like pennsylvania
as soon as the election is over and
axios
is reporting that trump has told
confidence he'll declare victory
tomorrow night
if it looks like he's ahead and fact
check
that is not how elections work the
president is also
defending and amplifying a caravan of
his supporters
who surrounded a biden campaign bus in
texas
forcing the biden team to cancel its
events
because of safety concerns that is the
state of the trump
campaign with one day to go until the
election day
it's not focused on the issues it's not
focused on the pandemic that's killed
230
000 americans and counting and on the
other side
there's joe biden
tomorrow we can put an end to a
president that has failed to protect
this nation
and tomorrow we can put an end to a
president has fanned the flames
of hate all across this country millions
of americans have already voted
almost 100 million have voted so far a
hundred million
voted already and more gonna vote today
last night trump said he was going to
fire dr fauci
isn't that wonderful i got a better idea
elect me and i'm gonna hire dr fauci
not and we're gonna fire donald trump
we're gonna beat this virus
and we're gonna get it under control i
promise you
look the first step to beating the virus
is beating donald trump
[Applause]
[Music]
with just hours to go in this campaign
we know who each of these candidates are
but there are so many lingering
questions
will the president declare victory
before all the votes are counted
and just how far will he go to challenge
vote tallies in court
also what will the country look like
when we all wake up
on november the 4th there are so many
questions that need answering
and my first guest is literally the
perfect person
to talk us through them all joining me
now is the legend
the one and only dan rather he is the
president
of news and guts media and co-author of
the book
what unites us reflections on patriotism
i am
so happy to talk to you this evening in
the midst of what
feels like living history so let's start
off with just your broad view
on the state of the race what's your
reaction been to
the closing messages we've seen from the
joe biden campaign
versus the donald trump campaign with
just one day to go
well first of all in the great arc of
history
we always argue that every presidential
race is important
but this does figure to be one of the
more consequential
presidential campaigns certainly of the
modern presidential era
that's number one number two as we go
through the last hours before the last
day
of voting to my surprise
uh president trump wants to go out on
the line he's going to fire
dr fauci uh that seems a a strange go
out line to me but
he chose that line i think he did so
because he understands that the
overriding narrative of the campaign
so far has been the virus has been
coronavirus
and joe biden and the democrats have
made that their number one theme
president trump likes to play offense
not defense but he's had to play such
fierce defense against that uh that he
invokes the firing of dr fauci
uh the best thing donald trump has going
for him
is there was some uh good economic news
a little earlier in the week
and i do think that gave him at least
some movement some momentum
but he's not emphasizing the economic
message he's going down saying you fire
found you so we shall see
i do think it's important to take a deep
breath you know
uh having covered this i covered my
first presidential campaign on the air
in 1952 if you can believe that
so much has changed but you know there's
an excitement about the election but as
you pointed out in your opening remarks
there's also a lot of anxiety
and a lot of worry and i would say just
as
a gentle advice for everybody who's
excited but also very worried about
the election and what may happen after
the election
uh just very respectfully i would submit
you know
hope is important hope pray
stay steady be patient patience is going
to be required as it generally is in
times of turbulence
and don't forget to breathe
definitely patience because one of the
things that we know to be true and you
as a veteran
journalist covering presidential
campaigns and elections
you know that they don't count all the
votes on election night
normally news outlets and uh those whose
job it is
is to announce winners um project
the winners without all of the ballots
being counted because
um there are usually a lot especially in
a state like california or in a state
where they're not
starting to count until election day
with that said do you
expect under those conditions with still
ballots to count the president will
ignore all of the historical precedent
and simply just declare himself the
winner before
the the process of counting all of the
ballots
is finished well i believe it because
president trump has already he
he has said out front that that's what
he plans to do
he plans to almost as soon as there's
any indication that votes have been
counted and he might have a lead
anywhere
he said he's he planned certainly people
around him have said i should correct
myself
but people around him said that this is
his plan to announce that he's won
see president trump has laid the
groundwork he's very carefully done
so but i think everybody including
people
who have voted or intended to vote for
president trump should keep in mind
it's this idea that president trump is
and those around him the
notion that votes cast on the last day
of voting on the tuesday of actual what
we used to call it
election day i prefer to call it vote
day are somehow more important
than votes that were cast by mayo or
absentee ballots or military ballots
that come in later
this is let's call it what it is this is
the lie this is untrue
they know it it's untrue and they know
it to be untrue but they're laying the
groundwork
to claim oh on the day on november 3rd
we got more votes than the other
candidate did
in the important electoral votes so
voila we win the election
well it's kind of as the sheriff used to
say
uh hold on whoa that's not the case and
i think people need to have that very
much in mind
and if i may point out because there's
so many people going to be tuned in
for election night who's not going to be
tuned into regular television
that delays in counting the votes
are very common they happen in every
election
and a delay in the counting of the vote
or reporting the count of the vote it
does not represent
that there's been misdeeds or fraud or
something
it's in the natural course of things and
by the way this idea that
votes that haven't been counted by the
end of
tomorrow evening should not count in the
election this is not something new we've
always had this for example
votes from people in the military
frequently don't get counted until
some days after the election itself so
as i say good time to say steady as we
go
be patient don't fall for a lot of false
ideas and
enjoy the ride
oh definitely enjoy the ride i mean
politics is one of those things where
it literally is human drama and so if
you are like me
who um i love a good story i feel like
politics
the human element is always so
unpredictable as the president
uh speaking of unpredictable continues
to sow the seeds of doubt surrounding
this election we know what he's
going to say to your point he's going to
declare victory
um and a record number but it may not
matter because a record number of
americans
are voting nearly 100 million people
have voted already
um so what does that tell you about this
state of the race
to me that that says people are engaged
they are involved what does it say to
you with with your veteran eye
on how elections and turnout
and what they say about the state of the
country itself
well first of all i want to see what the
turnout is tomorrow
on the final day of voting but another
thing that makes this camp
this presidential campaign unique is the
amount
of votes count cast
before the final vote day there's never
anything even
close to this nothing approaching it and
i would say my careful analysis not just
to my own one reason
one reason that we've had such a heavy
a pre-vote voting before the final
voting day
is because women have really turned out
in very strong numbers now there are a
lot of democrats who think well that's
good news for them
well we'll have to see when the votes
are counted but
something like 55 50 57
of the votes already in came from women
also the youth vote young people
really turned out so far now it may turn
out in the final analysis
that they don't go to go to the polls
tomorrow that they've already sent in
their votes so they don't go
but women and young voters are carrying
the democrats and if joe biden wins
it will be because he got uh so many
women going his way and so many
young people if donald trump wins it
will be because he held his base
and he sucked away he got away enough of
the african-american vote particularly
african-american men
and the uh latinx or hispanic vote
particularly
then he got enough of them to go his way
to put together his base to win i think
that's where we are if you had to bet it
and i recommend strongly you don't bet
uh
if you had to bet it you would say to
yourself well the importance look good
for joe biden
but you know overnight's a long time in
politics
a week is forever it may take a week to
decide this so i would
encourage no one jumping to any
conclusion i consider to be a very fluid
race
i do think that donald trump can win
there's at least
one clear path by which you can win if
he takes florida
and pennsylvania and managed to hold
both he can win
uh but coming down to it all the early
signs
point to abiding victory but that
doesn't mean that's going to be the
final outcome
that is all really important information
and a reality check for i think everyone
at home
dan rather thank you so much for sharing
your wisdom and your expertise and for
joining
stay safe out there we'll be watching
the results alongside
so many like you who have lived through
this many cycles
or many presidential campaigns and cycle
after cycle